another parent involved in a college
admissions scandal will be sentenced
today a prominent New York City lawyer
was given one month in prison for his
role in the scheme yesterday Gordon
Kaplan pleaded guilty to paying hit to
improve his daughter's score on a
college entrance exam Don Dahler spoke
to Kaplan's attorney it's the first
sit-down interview with a lawyer for any
of the parents involved in this candle
Don's outside the federal courthouse in
Boston done what else he is part of
Kaplan's sentence good morning well he
was also sentenced to a years probation
once he gets out of prison he has to pay
a fifty thousand dollar fine and do 250
hours of community service prosecutors
in court described him as lacking
morality and also not having any regard
for the law mr. Caplin would you answer
a few questions
Gordon Kaplan briefly addressed
reporters Thursday after leaving federal
court in Boston I fully respect the
decision of the court today
deeply and profoundly sorry for being
involved in this this mess
the former powerful New York Attorney
must spend one month behind bars
prosecutors had asked for eight calling
Kaplan brazen and corrupt in May he
pleaded guilty to one count of fraud and
conspiracy for paying seventy-five
thousand dollars to have the answers on
his daughter's a CT exam corrected this
conduct clearly crossed a line
Joshua levy is Kaplan's attorney do you
think this was maybe the best sentence
that you could have gotten I think that
the sentence of Felicity Huffman who
engaged in very similar conduct set the
floor a little bit I thought we maybe
could get a sentence compal to hers and
we came close last month act as Felicity
Huffman learned she must spend 14 days
in prison for paying $15,000 to have her
daughter's SAT exam corrected she liked
Kaplan pleaded guilty but 19 other
parents like Full House star Lori
Loughlin have entered not guilty pleas
Lachlan and her husband are accused of
paying $500,000 to have their two
daughters accepted into the University
of Southern California as crew recruits
no trial date has been set but this week
a judge said they're aiming for 20/20
there's a lot of aspects of the college
emission system that I hope get
revisited coming out of a case like this
maybe this spotlight is a good thing I
think it is caplet has to report to
prison on November 6 now he has
requested to do his time at a new
york-based low security prison known as
Otisville that also happens to be the
current residence of president Trump's
fixer Michael Cohen
Antonia was also where disgraced
Congressman Anthony Weiner did his time
very interesting Don thank you very much